o la paz en contra de la otan y en
contra de las guerras cientos de
personas están en las calles de madrid
que será la sede en unos pocos días de
la próxima reunión de los líderes de los
países integrantes de la organización
del tratado atlántico norte vuelo con
aquí en mi casco que es lo que dicen que
la guerra hace la paz eso es imposible
el único camino es la paz y por tanto
apostamos por su disolución por
establecer mecanismos internacionales de
seguridad y de cooperación entre las
naciones y por apostar claramente por la
paz y no por la guerra y la paz es
indisociable de las cuestiones que nos
preocupó hoy que usted está aquí pero
así la guerra la guerra no solamente
ucrania porque eso también en libia en
la eso también hijos ojo entonces la
otra es una fuerza de guerra no es una
fuerza de paz españa ahora mismo dedica
alrededor del 1 por ciento de su
producto interno bruto a gastos en
defensa una cifra que la otan pretende
se duplique para los aquí presentes ese
dinero debería redirigir a fines
sociales el presupuesto militar que va a
subir al 2% que la tranquila que es al
2% es una barbaridad y además ese es el
presupuesto que se ve dentro del
ministerio de defensa porque no hay
presupuesto militar que no se mete
dentro del ministerio de defensa que lo
meten por ejemplo en el ministerio de
exteriores como el empleo que hay ahora
en los ejércitos puede ir trasvasándose
el tema ecológico al tema de la
protección del medio ambiente al tema de
cuidar nuestros bosques los gastos
militares para escuelas y hospitales sí
con esta manifestación se cierra así la
anticumbre por la paz organizada en
madrid en la que varias organizaciones
piden
a raíz de la invasión de putin en
ucrania está ganando más apoyo
internacional y está haciendo que varios
países quieran unirse a ella